Pawn Stars fans were caught by surprise in
early 2016 when series star Austin Lee Russell,
better known as "Chumlee," was arrested for
drug and weapon possession as part of an ongoing
sexual assault investigation.
The truth is, we never really know the people
we like seeing on TV.
Time to put the hawking on hold as we look
at the untold truth about the cast of Pawn
Stars.
HUMAN SKULLS AND JAPANESE PORN
According to Rick Harrison, co-owner of the
World Famous Gold & Silver Pawn Shop, his
business has seen all kinds of weird items
come and go.
Surprisingly, human skulls and bizarre types
of Japanese pornography are the oddest items
anyone has ever brought into his shop to sell—which,
if you think about it, means he's kind of
gotten off easy over the years.
UNREAL REALITY
What you see on TV isn't quite what you get.
Given that attempting to film the actual day-to-day
life at a pawn shop would result in some pretty
boring television, it should come as no surprise
that the items you see brought into the Gold
& Silver Pawn Shop on the show have been vetted
beforehand.
This allows the guys to bring in all kinds
of experts who help them decide a fair price
for the items.
Additionally, due partly to Nevada privacy
laws, the Pawn Stars crew is prevented from
working at the actual Gold & Silver counter
while the cameras roll.
Instead, they film their scenes on a set that's
been designed to look like the store.
It's no surprise that not all the gold and
silver you see on your screen is the real
deal.
RICK MARRIED INTO A MESS
After Harrison wed legal worker Deanna Burditt
in 2013, tabloids reported that the lovebirds
were embroiled in a legal battle involving
Burditt's ex-husband, who was free on bail
while awaiting trial for a variety of sex-related
charges.
Deanna's ex was ultimately sentenced up to
15 years in prison for his offenses.
FIRED FOR BEING NAKED (SORTA)
Pawn Stars cast member Olivia Black lost her
gig on the show after nude photos of her surfaced,
exposing her previous career as a model for
SuicideGirls.
She later revealed that she was still an employee
of the store, as she was really only "fired"
in front of the cameras.
Black resumed her modeling career and sued
to get back on the show, ultimately leaving
her job at the store several months later.
SUED FOR MELTING STOLEN COINS
When you deal with the public for a living,
you really never know what's going to happen.
Harrison got a harsh reminder of this in 2014,
when his store was sued for melting down a
collection of gold coins that their former
owner alleged had been stolen and sold off
by his niece.
Although pawn shops in Nevada are required
to hold onto items for 30 to 90 days in case
the owners want them back, gold coins aren't
subject to that law—meaning the lawsuit
might have been an embarrassing hassle, but
it didn't pose much of a legal threat to the
store.
COREY HARRISON: STUNT CYCLIST
In 2014, Harrison was riding his bike while
collecting supplies for his birthday party
when a piece of his fender came off, sending
him into a high-speed tailspin.
Thinking fast, he avoided sailing into traffic
by jumping off his bike—and he still went
to the party before heading to the hospital,
where he learned he had a broken hand.
Harrison's no stranger to wrecks, either;
in 2011, he was in the news for wiping out
in the rain during a ride between Vegas and
San Diego.
Maybe it's time to start pawning the bikes.
PAWN STARS' BIG EXPANSION
Reality TV can be fickle, so credit is due
to Harrison for striking while the iron is
hot and using his fame as the foundation for
a business empire that now includes "Pawn
Plaza," a shopping center made out of old
shipping containers that sits next door to
the shop.
Among the tenants: Rick's Rollin' Smoke Barbecue
& Tavern, where Harrison intends to sit in
as a part-time bartender.
INTERNET DEATH HOAX
In the spring of 2013, word circulated that
Chumlee died of a heart attack.
These rumors were quickly debunked with a
tweet from the Pawn Stars cast member, who
told followers, "May we live long, Rich forever."
Time to start spending those riches on a good
lawyer.
NOT CHUMLEE'S FIRST RODEO
In 2012, cameras captured Chumlee in a brawl
with an unidentified man who approached him
and a group of friends while they were hanging
out on Hollywood Boulevard.
He later insisted he was fighting in self-defense,
and that the man was a stranger who was trying
to climb into his car.
"Self-defense" isn't a bad way to talk your
way out of a scuffle.
But good luck explaining the meth, the gun,
and everything else, Chumlee.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to see more
videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know what
surprised you the most about the Pawn Stars!